uh governor thank you for talking good
to see you
you have just decided to raise interest
rates you have told us that inflation is
going above seven percent
this feels like a big moment for
monetary policy in this country can you
explain what's happening we're having a
very big shock um particularly
from the prices of things that we buy
into the country so particularly energy
gas
i mean the wholesale gas price has gone
up i think it's around 400
in just over a year
for instance and also quite a lot of
traded goods that we buy in from other
parts of the world
and by the way one of the things that's
gone on in the covert period is that
there's been a sort of
shift from spending on services again
going out and so on to buying more goods
and that's around the world i mean this
country is part of it but it's by no
means the
largest part of it
and that has that has caused higher
inflation um energy prices particularly
the gas price have been extraordinarily
volatile as well
now
i have to tell you that we can't use
monetary policy to directly tackle the
causes of these increases
but what we have to do is use monetary
policy
particularly to
limit
what we tend someone's called the second
rating the second round affects the
follow-on effects
uh and that's a hard message i
understand for households because it's a
matter of saying
this is having a negative effect on on
income on real incomes
your decision is well the whole thing is
i mean obviously the higher
the biggest negative effect is coming
from higher inflation but you're then
adding to that with higher budgets but i
would say that it would be worse if we
didn't do it because if we get you know
if we get prolonged high inflation we
get even higher inflation that will be
worse
so that's the point it's between two
pretty undesirable outcomes we have
right now we have to
use monetary policy as
as as we can do
to seek
a rebalancing of you know particularly
of the domestic forces
now we believe that there will be a
slowdown in demand this year because
this effective of inflation on people's
incomes real incomes what caused that
and actually we believe that by the end
of the period that we look at two to
three years
inflation will come back to target and
we will stabilize
and what's what's your message to you
know to many households watching this
feeling that the already they're being
squeezed knowing that according to your
forecasts it's going to get worse isn't
it
what's what's your message to them
especially explaining
the fact that you're adding to that pain
well i i i would say that yes we are
having this
quite large
shock coming from
say particularly the prices of things
that we buy into this country
now
we believe that those prices will
correct
but there are all sorts of risks around
that but we believe our main belief is
that they will correct
and what we have to do is ensure that in
the meantime
there isn't more inflation pressure
coming domestically
and that would come for instance from i
have to say from things like wage
bargaining
um
and we have to
use monetary policy to in a sense
chart through that to say yes there is
going to be
i'm afraid some negative effect on
incomes there is going to be a negative
effect on growth in the economy
but we will come through it we really
believe we will come through this
it will correct itself
and that's essential because otherwise
it would be worse
well we would have higher inflation for
longer and that would have even more
effect on households incomes
and it would have even more effect on
demand it would have even more effect on
employment
and we don't want them we must avoid
that there's this kind of internet meme
i don't know if you've seen it you had
one job
well the bank of england has
one job keeping inflation under control
and yet
your target's two percent you're looking
at inflation being seven percent so
you have one job yes
but what we can't do
i'm afraid
is
remove all the shocks that can happen to
the economy that we can't do because
there are shocks coming into the economy
of all sorts i mean let's face it we've
had some very big shocks had coveted
shocks
we've now got a shock from
energy prices these are very big shocks
we're looking at about which she
couldn't really have done anything
no we're living in an era of very big
shocks
now our job is to stabilize inflation
you write to the target but we have to
do that over what we tend to call the
medium term that's two to three years
and we will do that i mean all our
policy is directed towards doing that
but we cannot i'm afraid you know remove
all the shocks off the scene because we
don't control the causes of them
so do you feel there was a kind of
opportunity missed here though because
you know
although you can't control everything
you know you do occasionally look back
at your numbers you look back at whether
you could have made a decision slightly
earlier
maybe you could have moved things up
marginally
do you wonder about those things
i
i'm afraid i do resist what i call
hindsight judgment so both you know in
our part in anybody else's part
it's just part of assessing whether you
wait
we went through a very very large
period of instability and shock in the
covert period
now let me say also that monetary policy
has its effect with a lag and that land
can go on for up to at least two years
if we had if we if we rewound the sort
of the
the the players that were and said
well you could have tightened monetary
policy two years ago well what what was
happening two years ago
we were in what were just going into the
teeth of the covet shock
and of course had we done that
let's say
we would have made the covid recession
even worse and that would have had
consequences today
but let me say today let me tell you
some good news
you know employment and unemployment
today
are much better than we've heard of it
they would be during the covert period i
mean we've come through the covid period
um better than we thought so that's the
challenge in making policy
final question you you know for a lot of
your career dreamed of being governor
did you have any kind of anticipation
that when when you became governor you'd
have to deal with an extraordinary
potential financial crisis with covid
and then this which is the toughest yeah
potentially the toughest moment for
independent monetary policy since the
bank was made well essentially i'm
coming up to my um second anniversary in
uh in early march
um
it hasn't been a quiet period yet put it
that way we've had some tough times but
you know we're here to deal with them i
mean that's what the bank of england is
here for and you know we get on with it
okay governor thank you very much